got to talk about a more important fight
that maybe on our hands ladies and
gentlemen and it's not Ukraine and
Russia it is Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg vox.com reporting why in the
world are Elon and Zuck planning to
punch each other their supposed cage
match has Petty online Roots
um all fours as the boys are fighting
okay I love this they are 51 and 39
years old respectively and we got to
inform you that they're gearing up for a
cage fight in an unconfirmed location
but possibly Las Vegas on a to be
decided date Elon Musk signaled his
interest in the match on Twitter a few
days ago Zuckerberg naturally confirmed
that he was he was in through Instagram
uh so what's the latest on this this is
this is going to happen or the latest is
Dana White uh came out and acknowledged
this is real they said they're very
serious about it they want to do it
coolest thing Zuckerberg has ever done
they're saying the weight class is like
the the different weight classes will
make it difficult for them I think this
is why they should go to Mars they
should have this fight yeah that's it's
like um but the other thing is like you
elon's mom was saying she doesn't want
him to do it I put a poll up on our chat
today I asked people I said you know who
do you think would win and I think
they're wrong I think people are saying
musk is going to win and I think if
you've seen the videos of of Zuckerberg
doing his doing Brazilian Jiu Jitsu he
looks like a robot when he's doing it
his face is completely blank I think I
think he ends up winning this one so
it if I just want to say this first the
first question is will this actually
happen and I lean towards it won't I
hope it does can you mention that the
insurance policy you'd have to have to
run this fight
there's a 37 second video this is a good
point why it won't happen because every
investor every every investor in
Facebook and every ancestor investor in
Tesla will file an injunction
immediately and be like
if one of you gets knocked out we're
gonna lose billions of dollars you know
that's a good point because Dana said
Dana White the owner of the UFC said
that it would raise a hundred million
dollars in pay-per-view and it'd be the
biggest most popular fight of all time
um but you're right ahead trauma to Elon
Musk could end Tesla and then they're
just like you make one bad decision and
you're bored votes you out there like we
saw you get hit in the head by
Zuckerberg like you we can't trust you
to make decisions musk is 51 yeah and
Zuckerberg's a trained I mean I don't
know how trained but a trained Jiu Jitsu
fighter all right so let's let's talk
about this though Zuckerberg does
Jujitsu he does there's that video that
went viral where he claimed the ref
claimed that he tapped out but he didn't
and Zucker got all got all mad about it
uh Elon Musk is just a guy however Elon
Musk is also much much much larger than
Zuckerberg Zuckerberg's actually a
little dude also five eight or something
did they get to five seven 154 150
what's what's musk uh six one six two
and uh 195 which I think is kind of
conservative for his weight he looks
pretty big no way he's won that's what
he's listed as minimum so what yeah
I'm saying it's a minimum oh his height
is six one six two right for that height
alone with his build he's looking at 2
10 to 20. so my executive producer just
went to Twitter and met with Elon Alx
he's been on the show everyone knows hey
awesome great dude follow him on Twitter
blue pass 500 000 and also by the way
Benny Brigade thank you for one million
Subs this week we just crossed that uh
Milestone on Wednesday so God bless you
thank you Alx has been my executive
producer for five years met with Elon
Musk and he's like yo I'm 5'2 Alex is
I'm sorry six two at Alex is every bit
of a tall dude all right neon Moss was
taller than him wow Elon Muslim it was a
big guy hey Alex tweeted he's like yeah
Elon Musk way bigger than I thought he'd
be in person have you seen the photos of
him on the on the boat with Bezos he's a
he's a big dude he's a big big dude also
the the other thing for it for for musk
is like I just don't know if like can
they find the time to do something like
this is there really time to to get
something like this done uh when you're
running five companies I think so
because they're both robots you know and
they know that time is relative so when
you create a piece of art that goes on
the internet that is seen 100 million
times it creates like when you think of
time you're creating a hundred billion
minutes as opposed to spending maybe 7
000 minutes to get it done you you've
actually made more time more importantly
if than if they can find the time to do
this is is Elon going to make the time
to train because Zuckerberg and he's
younger than him and you know he is
fighting right now and he's training
with the best he's a billionaire like he
can afford anybody so can Elon but Elon
Andrew Tate says I'll train you Jorge uh
Jorge Mazda doll says I'll train you
Elon Musk there's been a bunch of MMA
fighters that are like yeah I will train
you Sam Hyde Sam Hyde huh he's the guy
no I think I think Andrew Tate if he
goes to Romania and trains with Andrew
Tate that would be hardcore because even
that would be awesome to watch you live
in such a weird world where it's like
you just kind of accepted this dude who
might or might not be a human trafficker
is gonna train the guy who runs five of
the biggest companies in the world to
fight another dude who's worth more than
some small country's GDP and you're just
like whatever like like back in the day
this would have happened on Celebrity
Death Match no more
take the cartridge out blow on it put it
back in let's go reset the game you just
accept that like is this dude who's
maybe guilty of unspeakable crimes
really possibly going to train this dude
who's now got people mad at him because
he won't let them say sis on Twitter
it's it's a weird world we live in you
think it's a good idea for them to fight
I I mean yeah because I think I'm I'm
all for the hilarity of it all I think I
think it's hilarious but like I mean if
I was an investor in either these
companies I don't know if I want the guy
especially musk who's like the
brainchild of those companies Facebook
is kind of its own thing now right right
face like I think Facebook does find if
if Zuckerberg isn't around anymore musk
is very much a forward-facing Persona
that is the face of those companies you
can't have that dude coming out here
looking like Reagan in the second
Administration and like looking like he
doesn't know what he's talking about
right like he has to be coherent he has
to know what he's talking about he has
to look like he's on this game all the
time two two things one um do you well
first of Elon Musk smoked with Joe Rogan
and Tesla stock plunged immediately so
this would have an impact if he got
knocked great time to buy something to
be worried about and number two
um do you guys are you guys a little bit
worried that Bezos is getting into shape
Zuckerberg is doing MMA like they know
something we don't know like no they
didn't know something most people don't
know and it's you got to eat right take
care of yourself that's just it that's
right do you think they're preparing for
something where they might have to do
engage in Mortal physical combat like
it's societal collapse no no no I mean
Bezos is in shape because he's got his
new wife he's gonna take his other half
of his mind I think if you take a look
around you'll notice a few things people
are drinking a lot less I mean I've
noticed we've noticed that anecdotally
because we do this great boo selection
and people come in and we hear this all
the time oh I stopped drinking recently
we also know that Millennials drink a
ridiculously lower amounts of soda than
past Generations yeah it's the first
time in American history that so does
not like the number one drink in America
I mean I hate us we have these uh these
liquid deaths where the total sugar
count is 6 grams I've actually in this
whole can I've gone to kombucha uh it's
not expensive you get a lot of it it's
it's like a sweet tea fermented no sugar
it says yes I think they sweeten it with
an alcohol show but this is my point
when it comes to all of these guys we
see them they're very visible but the
reality is the trend and getting
healthier is just across the board well
you should the wealthy dewy better than
us the covet it was Cove it freaked me
out I I'm fully focused on physical yeah
tell that to Bill Gates though Bill
Gates Ian has a filet mignon every day
every day a a nice wagyu beef yes raw
raw it's just kidding it's good to have
your Heroes and the people that you look
up to in society be masculine men if
you're a man it's good to have
testosterone flowing through your veins
Mr Beast tweeted recently that he's
getting in shape and that he he called
himself obese and that he's been
training every single day and eating
right and uh stopping drinking and I
think this is a wonderful example the
set for young men actually you shouldn't
want to be a slob filled with
microplastics and unable to defend
yourself or support your family in my
case physically support my family
because I need to pick my little kids up
and down if you know or walk up the
stairs right to literally be a father
you have to be a masculine man you have
to have energy if if not a cage match
for the issue of the stock and potential
lawsuits and injunctions they need to do
some kind of like manually sporting
competition arm wrestling
I'm wrestling baby we're not gonna get
hurt they're not gonna get hurt arm
wrestling at least not not severely
like the helmet thing but maybe wear
like helmets right or something
Americans
they do that with the giant toothpicks
that feels very musk to me like there's
a meme there's meme potential in that
that I think that's a good one maybe we
do like a like five events it's like arm
wrestling it's the giant Q-tip thing
where they you know Bop each other with
them and maybe maybe a soccer bopper on
a bridge where it's
so I do want to say this as somebody who
was raised in Iowa that don't count out
Zuck because he's shorter or smaller
we've been having this like size
comparison to elon's Big Man like dude
these short guys growing up in Iowa the
reason I say that is because wrestling
country everyone's a wrestler yep and
these little guys these little guys who
wrestled featherweight like one one uh
120 right 120 or 110. they're little
dudes and they have those cauliflower
ears they will kick your ass those guys
will cause you more pain it's actually
little guys at the bar with cauliflower
ears you got to stay away from well
those guys will hurt you there's a uh
I don't know if I'm supposed to tell the
story so I'll just keep it very vague
but someone we know who's a fighter said
that he was at a bar once and some guy
was mouthing off and he was like just
leave me alone dude and then his
brother's like dude dude dude stop and
points into his ears oh yeah he said
that on the show I was watching that
show yeah that was awesome yeah and it's
just like I'm I'm pretty sure like you
see that and you're like it's not that
they're a good fighter it's that they
are a fighter and you are not don't
don't go in that room also when you're
little like you always feel like you
have something to prove never piss off a
short cop ever in your entire life
that's the worst thing in the entire
Community because they're quick to anger
and they're always going to be trying to
prove themselves just don't do it so if
this fight if this fight comes to term I
prophesy Zuckerberg goes for there's
gonna be some weak weak strikes
Zuckerberg goes for the legs wraps them
up really fast puts him in some pain
that he wasn't expecting and and musk is
out that's my then the undercard can be
all of the people that work for their
companies like their vice president's
fight and I I love it I love it you know
it would be even better though if
they're if they're in the middle of
their fight all of a sudden there's like
an a sound or a horn trumpet and then
they look up in the rafters and there's
Jack Dorsey and then he like ropes down
yes like Shawn Michaels yeah exactly
that's right and then you start hearing
this like glitchy house music and Elon
Musk calls in a Tesla bot that and comes
and takes his place TAPS in just like an
ai ai versus Zuck yeah and then Zuck
rips his human exoskeleton off his face
and he's like lizard people they fight
right AI versus the Lizard people they
finally have the battle we've all been
waiting for somebody could just make
this movie now we don't need this to
actually happen and Joe Rogan's calling
it right Joe Rogan's there hold on hold
on can we just can we just go back to
reality for one second Joe Rogan will be
calling them calling the fight how
insane so when we saw that story where
it was uh Trump's in the audience with
like was like Kid Rock and like who else
was there Mike Tyson Mike Tyson and I'm
just like what what's this Dana White
Donald Trump Donald Trump Kid Rock Mike
Tyson and Joe Rogan's in there calling
the I'm like this is the weirdest we
live in a simulation they just tell me
I'm sorry that's just it Rogan we got to
give some credit to Joe Rogan this guy
people love him obviously but like he
brought people together humans together
across so many strata of reality like it
is so awesome to watch doctors hang out
with Fighters sorry Penny were you about
to say something I'm just everyone's
saying that uh Donald Trump needs to be
the ref oh that'll be hot get him a nice
pin white stripe black and white striped
shirt I I have so much love for Rogan
not only just because of what he's doing
with the show but the fact that the
grand macro scheme of what he's how he's
been able to bring people together I
think I'd rather have Trump do
announcement with Rogan oh yeah I think
he would be better off in the announce
Booth like it's the color commentator
yeah that would be amazing it's against
tremendous
Trump would be biased against Zuckerberg
right yeah in the fight that's funnier
it's funnier if he has like clear face
favorites that he's picking he's gonna
run all his grievances against both of
them he's like this guy begged me for
support during us
now he's gonna submit so the real
question we'd ask is like how do we make
something like this actually happen even
if it was WWE style where it's all fake
and silly and over the top would be the
best thing ever that was my pitch it's
like they should just have WWE do it
because you could actually write story
lines for these people and it would be
really really funny to watch the The
Writers come up with something
absolutely ridiculous
Bezos like
shows up and then it's like Battle
Royale and they're all just in the rain
Bezos comes in and helps Zuckerberg
Bezos and then Dorsey comes in and helps
Elon Elon because he's like yeah you're
my Twitter brother in arms he bought you
bought it for me and they become the
Twitter tag team for us like let's do
this this is this is the per it is a
simulation right Jack Dorsey is wearing
Twitter 1.0 and elon's wearing Twitter
2.0 shirt suddenly like the lights go
out in the entire Arena and you hear I
don't know some type of Latin music from
the Amazon and in comes an Amazon drone
with an Amazon box and in the box of
Jeff Bezos
he bursts out of it right he comes in an
Amazon truck they back up an Amazon
and the guy's got a with a box that he
carts into the into the into the cage
and they're like What's this then he
puts it down and then also and it just
bursts open and basically and there's
precedent for this because Stone Cold
Steve Austin and he's like I'm in my
Prime Stone Cold Steve Austin once drove
a a beer truck to the ring and jumped on
Vince McMahon we can have Bezos drive an
Amazon truck to the ring and just jump
on top of both of them this is perfect
let's do this I want to see like them
bust like Elon pickup Zuck and like
smash him through the ground and as he
falls down lands on like the next scene
which is they're fighting on a Starship
and then can we make that happen The
Babylon B had a meme today that said
like Zuckerberg and Elon saw their
differences by playing GoldenEye 64 only
slapping each other in two player mode
but you got to play on a license to kill
mode where one hit kills if yeah and
then you're like oh like this back and
forth like that one of them takes
blofeld because he's smaller so they
can't actually slap him oh sorry yeah
what did you say low flow blowfeld who's
that that's another character oh really
no odd job is the short one yeah and we
always had the no odd job rule yeah yeah
yeah Jaws sucked too he threw his hat
yeah people the best who would be the
one person that like unites them all
right because that's the thing you need
if you're writing the WWE script some
somebody has to show up at unite then
they have to forejoin forces right like
the Power Rangers
Communist party like if anyone's opposed
to the the oligarchs you know what I
mean like they have to be like Logan
Paul but Xi Jinping would be the best
heel Xi Jinping would be amazing evil
the like the bad owners he'd love it too
that's right the sweat shops in the
background WWE always did the like the
evil Foreigner stereotype and all of
them the Iron Sheik just passed away so
Jesus paying would have to take over for
that she doesn't have to say anything he
just kind of stand there and like chill
and smile a little bit and you're like
do I trust him or not I don't know put
him in a Winnie the Pooh outfit yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time